lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
ordenar estos números de izquierda a
derecha del más chico al más grande pero
primero quiero que le pongas pausa el
vídeo y trates de resolverlo por tu
cuenta muy bien antes de que lo
resolvamos juntos bueno suponiendo que
ya lo intentaste vamos a resolverlo
juntos aunque queremos ordenar estos
números del más chico al más grande y
para eso es súper útil tener una recta
numérica a la mano lo bueno es que yo
tengo por aquí arriba una recta numérica
y lo que vamos a hacer es ir colocando
cada uno de estos números en la recta
numérica el primer número que vamos a
poner en la recta numérica son siete
tercios
siete tercios pero para ponerlo en la
recta numérica sería mucho más fácil
escribir a este número como un número
mixto y para hacer esto tenemos que
sacar los enteros aunque los enteros son
tres tercios
así es que podemos escribir a esta
fracción como tres tercios y ahí estamos
sacando un entero más otros tres tercios
tres tercios y por el momento llevamos
seis tercios entonces nada más nos falta
a sumar un tercio y lo que tenemos son
tres más tres más 17 tercios
ahora esto de aquí es un entero y esto
de aquí es otro entero entonces también
podemos escribir esto como dos enteros y
un tercio y así es mucho más fácil
dibujarlo en esta recta numérica aunque
porque estamos aquí en el cero y para
llegar a dos enteros y un tercio lo que
tenemos que hacer es saltar dos enteros
a la derecha y luego nos falta saltar
únicamente un tercio de un entero y
bueno aquí está padre porque tenemos a
este entero dividido en tres pedazos
iguales dividido por estas marcas
entonces tenemos que justo aquí es dos
enteros y un tercio o sea que aquí está
siete tercios bueno y ahora vamos con
menos cinco medios y vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo tenemos por aquí
menos cinco medios
y eso es igual a menos 5 medios lo
podemos dividir en la suma de dos medios
que es un entero más otro entero más y
aquí nada más nos falta sumar un medio
aunque hay otra vez
este es un entero este es otro entero y
entonces nos queda aquí tenemos un signo
de menos menos dos enteros dos enteros y
un medio y un medio
así es que menos cinco medios se
encuentra por aquí que partimos del 0 -
1 - 2 y luego queremos restarle otro
menos un medio y para restarle otro
menos un medio tenemos que llegar a la
mitad entre el siguiente entero y el
entero en el que estamos
osea justo por aquí a la mitad entonces
menos 5 medios se encuentra aquí menos 5
medios
todos tenemos el 0 que es muy fácil
porque yo está marcado aquí en la recta
numérica el 0 está por aquí luego
tenemos menos 2 que también está súper
fácil porque también lo tenemos escrito
en nuestra recta numérica y sin nada
pues partiendo del 0 tendríamos que
saltar 2 enteros a la izquierda o sea
está aquí menos 2 y luego tenemos este
menos 12 entre 4 lo cual está bastante
sencillo también porque es un número
entero que es menos 3 ahora si lo
queremos hacer con calma para que no nos
confundamos entonces ponemos por aquí
menos 12 entre 4 y siguiendo esta misma
lógica esto es un menos
sacamos un entero que son cuatro cuartos
más otro entero que son otros cuatro
cuartos porque llevamos ocho cuartos y
finalmente otro cuatro cuartos aunque yo
aquí tenemos doce cuartos entonces es un
entero este es otro entero este es otro
entero así es que tenemos menos tres
enteros o sea este número de aquí y esto
de aquí es menos doce cuartos y
finalmente llegamos al último número que
tenemos que colocar en la recta numérica
que es menos 3.25 ahora podemos
transformar esto en una fracción bueno
en un número mixto aunque hay porque
menos 3.25 lo podemos ver como menos
tres enteros y 25-25 entre
ahora 25 centésimas es igual a un cuarto
porque hay 25 es la cuarta parte de 100
entonces esto es igual a menos tres
enteros y un cuarto
así es que aquí en la recta numérica
partimos del 0 y saltamos un entero dos
enteros tres enteros y después tenemos
que saltar otro cuarto hacia la
izquierda y no lo vamos a poder hacer de
una forma muy exacta pero si tenemos una
idea de por dónde está ok un cuarto es
más chico que un tercio este es un
tercio pero no es tanto más chico
entonces menos tres y un cuarto está más
o menos por aquí así es que por aquí
está menos
es punto 25 así es que queríamos ordenar
estos números del más chico al más
grande y ya lo tenemos aquí en la recta
numérica aunque el más chico es menos
3.25 después el segundo más chico es
menos doce cuartos después menos cinco
medios menos 20 y siete tercios y listo
ya terminamos